and welcome to Hannity and tonight we
are back live with a studio audience by
the way it is three degrees outside in
New York City by the way you don't want
to live there
um and all these people came out thank
you for coming out in the cold weather
uh I know it was rough for you and as
always by the way the audience will get
the last word tonight we have a lot of
news to get to today we begin with a 60
000 foot in the sky uh balloon that's
flying over the continental U.S
somewhere where at this moment we're not
exactly sure it is a massive Chinese spy
balloon the size of say three school
buses it has been hovering over our
country for days and why hasn't our
government told we the people uh about
this they are the self-proclaimed most
transparent Administration in history
China says it's a weather balloon I
don't believe them anyone here believe
them you can say it louder
oh all right they're saying accidentally
he's flying over America's critical
military infrastructure now it's
happening in multiple States a lying
communist spokesperson named Mao told us
to calm down quote any deliberate
speculation or hyping up will not help
the Chinese side is gathering the facts
and hopes all sides will handle this
matter in a cool-headed manner how about
we don't need lectures from the
Communist Chinese and yeah no doubt
they're Gathering facts about our
military bases our nuclear facilities
and God knows what else now I have an
idea how about China gets their asses
out of our airspace and if we don't
we'll blow them out of our airspace
all right
don't they have enough people to surveil
back in their own country that what 1.4
billion Chinese citizens they treat like
prisoners or what about the minority
uyghurs that have been persecuted and
they're trying to exterminate and by the
way are we supposed to be cool-headed
when a spy balloon is hovering over the
U.S and our nuclear sites all while
China is throwing a complete and total
hissy fit every single time an American
official wants to visit an Allied
country called Taiwan where they say
they want to reunify with now the last
time Pelosi visited our Pacific Ally the
CCP they threatened targeted military
operations against us and China even
claimed that global stability was ruined
because Mike Pompeo who will join us in
a moment congratulated taiwan's
president on a second term well we're
just supposed to be what calm cool
Collective relaxed about a Chinese spy
balloon hovering over our country in our
airspace so I have another question
question why haven't we shot this
balloon out of the sky oh Joe Biden is
the president he is refusing to take any
action as of now apparently this has
gone on for days he won't even talk
about it he doesn't want to answer the
questions about the little balloon he
doesn't have time for The Situation Room
where he should have been all day with
our top military leaders but no Joe
Biden this weekend is back to Delaware
for rest and relaxation now this is this
a joke to him because it's not to me
this seems to me to be a serious uh
security threat to this country and Joe
if you don't want to be president if you
can't handle it if you don't want to
work overtime if it's too much work for
you you can go away you can leave and
you can stay in Delaware and don't
bother coming back and please don't
leave us with the giggling vice
president because I don't think she
knows what to do either anyway any
competent leader right
you I thought Joe was bad I'm beginning
to think she's worse I really am
competent leader Democrat Republican
would be in Washington in The Situation
Room managing this crisis China has
breached our airspace they're now spying
on us but the administration says it is
too much of a risk to shoot the balloon
down they say they are worried that
debris might hit a population Zone keep
in mind the Drone first flew over a
Barren part of Alaska the White House
they took no action it then Flew Over
the vast prairies and mountain ranges of
Montana and by the way even flew flew
over our ICBM launch sites and the White
House took no action and didn't tell us
it was probably close to some of that
Farmland China's been buying Farmland
all over the country they've been buying
Ranch Land all over the country they've
been buying land near our military
installations all over the country now
do you think the Chinese would ever let
Americans buy their Farmland their Ranch
land or buy land near their military
installations I would say the odds are
zero and by Biden wants to sell what
more of our strategic petroleum reserves
to the Chinese after he depleted it down
to a 40 to 50 year low then stop wasting
our money he's simply not fit to be
president and we have to ask the
question did his high dollar family
business dealings with China compromise
his ability to do the right thing in
this moment of Crisis right now by the
way we don't exactly know where the
balloon is flying that's not good news
either according to a pentagon
spokesperson if the American people want
to know the location of the China spy
balloon you only need to look up in the
sky
they said that take a look as I
mentioned right now it's over the center
of the continental United States that's
about as specific as I'm going to get I
understand I'm being convenient but as
the public not have a right to know uh
the public certainly has the ability to
look up in the sky and and see where the
balloon is hang on hold on let me look
up in the sky I don't see maybe it's not
in New York yet look I'm glad we still
have the ability to look up in the sky
which is a privilege
um but is it just me or does the Biden
Administration see seem to have more
contempt for we the American people that
our number one geopolitical foe now as
we speak Vladimir Putin our number two
geopolitical foe he is planning to
launch a Hypersonic missile capable of
hitting the United States during a war
this is during war games uh a drill that
he's doing with China simulating an
attack on the east coast of the U.S but
Joe Biden is still refusing to supply
Ukraine or allow Europe to supply
Ukraine with the fighter jets that they
need to win the war against Russia so
make no mistake here's something deeply
wrong with the president that is quick
to call Republicans a threat to the
country but will not stand up to Russia
or even take action against a Chinese
reconnaissance spy balloon flying over
U.S military bases in contrast today
former president Donald Trump he
released this video on what is a real
clear present danger and that is the
growing threat from the Communist
Chinese take a look
as president I took the most dramatic
action of any Administration to curtail
China's ability to conduct Espionage in
the United States and when I'm back in
the White House those efforts will be
expanded in a very very big way instead
of hunting down Republicans they
reformed FBI and justice department will
be hunting down Chinese spies hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else